اولا طبعا
هناك مراحل ايضا سابقه قبل الامام سعود بن
عبد العزيز بن سعود بن عبد العزيز بن محمد
بن سعود وكان والده الامام ايضا عبد
العزيز محمد بن سعود وكان ايضا الايمان
محمد بن سعود عندما شرع ايضا محمد بن سعود
في هذه الانطلاق الكبرى وايضا محاوله
لملمه هذه البلاد المتراميه الاطراف
وخصوصا في منطقه العارض استطاع ايضا هناك
يقوم بحملات عسكريه ايضا مدينه الرياض
استمرت 28 سنه 28 سنه الحقيقه التاريخ ليس
سهلا وايضا هناك حوادث تاريخيه بينه ايضا
بين الرياض ربما بلغت اكثر من 34 موقع
تاريخيه قتل فيها الحقيقه عدد يعني من اهل
الدرعيه وايضا في الرياض كان محمد بن سعود
ايضا يسعى لهذه السيطره وايضا لملمه هذه
الاطراف المتناحره في هذه المنطقه
وبالتالي استطاع وتمكن ايضا من دخول
الرياض في 19 ربيع الاول تقريبا في عام
1127 في يوم العصر فاستطاع الامام بعد
وفاته طبعا الامام محمد بن سعود تولى
الامام عبد العزيز ايضا اكمال المسيره
وايضا دخول الرياض فتوسعت بالتالي هذه
الدوله فاستطاعت ايضا هذا التوسع الذي ادى
الى دخول الرياض في الدوله السعوديه ان
تتوسع ايضا وتتمدد من ناحيه الجنوبيه
وغيرها ثم انتشر ايضا هذا التوسع الكبير
وبلغ اثره في عهد الامام سعود بن عبد
العزيز بن محمد بن سعود سعود بن عبد
العزيز يسمى سعود الكبير وهو اقصى فتره
الحقيقه بلغت اوجه الدوله السعوديه العهد
الذهبي ام من شمال الجزيره العربيه من
جنوب حوران الى ايضا الحديده من جنوب
حوران الى شمال حديده وايضا من البحر الى
البحر فاستقر الحقيقه الدوله السعوديه
ومناسبه خلف بن هذال الله يعافيه ويشفيه
في احدى روائعه لا تشتبه بالخوارط والحدود
الحدود من الحديده لاقصى كربل بس على ذكر
حينما ذكر الحقيقه برزت ايضا في هذه
الدوله وايضا دخول موارد جديده وايضا
التوسع العسكري والتوسع الثقافي وايضا
التوسع العلمي فاصبح الناس ايضا يشعرون
بمدى اهميه الدوله وبماذا ايضا ما يلم
جراحهم من ناحيه الامنيه لان كان الجزيره
العربيه يضرب فيها المثل عدم الاستقرار
الامن لكن لكن انا اريد نشات الدوله الان
ما هي مظاهر وعظمتها وتميزها ان لذلك مثلت
بعهد لانه العهد الذهب هو مظاهر العمرانيه
تحدثنا عن قصر الطريف هذا هو المظاهر
الحقيقه متعدده وجورا ايضا مختلفه وربما
ايضا لها دراسات كبيره حقيقه جدا يعني
مثلا الطريف اذا اخذنا على سبيل المثال في
الدرعيه برزت ايضا الدرعيه في بنائها
العمراني وايضا تطورها الحضاري في تلك
الفتره فايضا برز ايضا قصر الطريف المشهور
قصر الطريف لانه يقع الدرعيه على طرف
الوادي والحجاج الوادي تصغير الطرف لان
الدرعيه نخوتها القديمه اهل العوجه العوجه
من اعوجاج الوادي فاستطاع ايضا الامام عبد
العزيز واكمل هذا المشروع الامام سعود في
بناء ايضا الاحياء المجاوره ايضا في
الدرعيه في حي الطريف واستطاع ايضا بناء
قصر الحكم الذي يمارسون فيه ايضا القياده
والاداره واصبح هناك قصر مشهور يطلق عليه
قصر سلوى هذا اللي هو البناء الشعب هذا
المتبقي نعم هذا المتبقي هو هذا بناه
الامام سعود ولا يعرف الحقيقه ما هي
الاسباب التي سميت عليه سلوى باسم زوجه هل
ايضا بسلوى الروح هل بالطير هل باسم اخر
لكن جعله الامام سعود الذين يفيدون وايضا
الناس والشعراء الذين يلفون عليه في هذا
المكان وايضا يدير الناحيه الحكم والاداره
في هذا المكان وكان الامام مسعود ايضا له
اوجه مختلفه في قضيه ايضا حصر بعض الاشياء
والجوانب المختلفه من ناحيه التجاره ضبطها
ومن ناحيه ايضا العلماء وضبطهم من ناحيه
الفتوى